bonjour et merci d'être avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france alors avant de se
pencher sur le gouvernement d'haydn
donald trump accepte donc la transition
ça va évidemment facilité les choses
qu'est ce qui a pu lui décidé selon vous
il n'a pas vraiment accepté la
transition il a accepté de verser les
faux de de la transition mais il n'a pas
du tout renoncé contester l'élection il
a toutes les raisons de contester
l'élection dans la mesure où il ya des
trous massives qui ont eu lieu et je
dirais qu'un président qui prétend
gouverner le pays sur la base de fraudes
massives est un président qui n'a pas de
légitimité et je pense que beaucoup de
gens aux etats-unis vont continuer très
longtemps à contester la légitimité que
pourrait avoir une hypothétique
administration baida north side donald
trump à accepter cela c'est pour une
raison très clair à qui les nourrissent
dans son communiqué c'est que emily
murphy qui est chargé de cela est
quelqu'un qui a fui des menaces de
multiples menaces et donc il a préféré
que les menaces cesse et je dirais que
lorsqu'on se livrent à des menaces
contre quelqu'un qui appartient à une
administration on se conduit d'une
manière indigne mais ce n'est pas que là
qu'il ya eu des menaces il ya une
situation très trouble actuellement aux
etats-unis et certaines parties de cette
situation de trekking donc de notre côté
de relâche à défaut mais il n'a pas du
tout renoncé à contester l'élection va
se focaliser sur quelques profils a en
particulier l'avant cela quel regard
portez vous sur les premiers grands noms
donnés en général 2
de l'équipe joe biden je dirais que ces
noms sont des gens qui viennent de
l'administration obama
ce sont des gens qui ont travaillé pour
les administrations obama est donc je
dirais que c'est d'une certaine manière
une administration obama
3 ce sont des gens qui avaient des
postes de second rang dans
l'administration obama 2 et qui
maintenant vont se retrouve au premier
rang la seule exception c'est anthony
blinken
les autres appartiennent avec atv qu à
la catégorie que je viens de finir mais
je dirais que le plus important ce n'est
pas cela à mes yeux le plus important
c'est la politique que ces gens vont
mener parce que ces gens sont des
instruments au service d'une politique
et cette politique elle a été définie
par un bon commentateur concernant et
blaine kalou par exemple il a été dit
qu'il allait revenir dans l'accord sur
le nucléaire iranien
et cet accord sur le nucléaire iranien
est quelque chose qui est
potentiellement très dangereux l'iran
est très proche de l'armé nucléaire
l'iran avant que donald trump ne sorte
de l'accord de juillet 2015 était un
pays qui était devenu le principal
financier du terrorisme islamique équité
stabilise à toute la région et je dirais
qu'il ya beaucoup de pays de la région
où les pays du monde arabe sunnite et
israël qui se méfie beaucoup et qui sont
très inquiet des décisions qui peuvent
être prises si je brydon arrive au
pouvoir
et si anthony blinken arrive lui même au
pouvoir quentin en yvelines gagnent 0,6
chargé de revenir dans l'accord de les
accords de paris sur le climat et je
dirais que revenir dans ces accords sera
quelque chose qui sera très délétère
pour l'économie américaine les
etats-unis sont devenus indépendants sur
un plan énergétique et son homme devenu
le premier producteur de gaz et de
pétrole mondial et je dirais que c'est
quelque chose qui leur a donné un poids
supplémentaire sur la planète à gaz
nombre de problèmes et je dirais qu'on
va se retrouver peut-être dans une
situation où les états unis vont cadre
cette position donc je dirais que si
l'on regarde la situation qui était
celle de la planète à la fin de
l'administration obama
on voyait qu'il n'y avait jamais eu
autant de réfugiés dans le monde depuis
on voyait qu'il y avait du terrorisme
partout beaucoup de gens oublient que le
terrorisme qui a frappé le bataclan en
france par exemple d'y attraper
manchester au royaume uni c'est du
terrorisme qui a lieu sans obama
beaucoup de gens oublient les immenses
pack de réfugiés qui sont arrivés par la
turquie et qui sont arrivés le par la
libye et qui sont arides en europe et
qui ont déstabilisé l'europe et que tout
cela s'est passé sous obama à la sublime
khan chef de la diplomatie américaine si
cela est confirmé john kerry lui a
choisi pour donc le retour des
etats-unis dans l'accord sur le climat
il sera l'émissaire spécial de john
dryden alejandro mayorkas ce
un hispanique à la sécurité intérieure
voilà pour les quelques grands noms qui
ressort de la future équipe joe biden
une équipe qui devra composer avec le
congrès et le sénat
le congrès est composé de la chambre des
représentants la chambre des
représentants aux mains des démocrates
bien qu'ils ont perdu beaucoup de sièges
le sénat reste pour le moment au moins
des républicains mais il reste une
élection exactement deux élections
sénatoriales qui doivent avoir lieu
aujourd'hui et si les démocrates
remportent tous ses deux sièges
aujourd'hui ils auront les pleins
pouvoirs et cela inquiète beaucoup de
gens parce qu'ils envisagent dans ce
cas-là de réformes et de changer
complètement les institutions
américaines en commençant par la cour
suprême
donc les et les deux élections
sénatoriales georgia vont être appelés
manque crucial les démocrates vont
mettre tout leur poids pour gagner ces
élections et les républicains vont tout
faire pour que les démocrates ne les
gagne merci merci d'avoir pris le temps
de répondre à nos questions ce matin guy
millière cherche harrogate institute et
auteur de cet ouvrage
après trump c'est aux éditions balland